et d'ailleurs comme il fait le malin va
l'envoyer en garde à vue à la mairie le
début vous disent que vous aimez
beaucoup cette rubrique est très drôle
c'était le moment ou jamais d'y passer
je vous laisse aux mains du commissaire
guy armes de lormont mathieu va
présenter l'ours quel chien sera à la
hauteur
en plus ils tombent viré après deux
émissions est le seul animateur qui
s'est fait remplacer par labrador comme
carrière c'est pas au jeu mais aussi
j'ai remarqué que tu étais un petit peu
trop tactile avec cyril hanouna
je te rappelle que c'est en patron pas
ton ipad
j'ai le rapport sous les yeux 28
conquête cet été tu te taper pis de mais
quand on en était que taylor swift ont
tout séduit et je représente est prévu
d'en faire une chanson paille jason
orange foot s'est passé à 700 visage
vous que ces jarres et toutes les photos
sur internet entre les placements de
produits la musculation ya plus de
protéines dont on compte instagram que
dans 100 g de blancs de poulet tu
soulèves plus de poids que les oreilles
de morini bosc
avant je ne jeûne pas 44 ans toi j'en ai
37 et ressembles à ton père tu manges
quoi défectueux
jacky loomans occulter les vrais stages
et bruno le maire alors chroniqueur le
soir ministre de l'économie la journée
je vais te [ __ ] au trou pour cumul des
mandats l'alevinage de jouer enfin sur
scène dans son spectacle féerique à
l'apollo théâtre appareils alors à
amener les traders franchement très
drôle mais arrêtez bruno le maire qui
trouvent que bruno le maire au moins
beau ouais c'est ridicule homogène bras